[Music]
three
two action hello welcome back to
or off the record where we talk about
whatever we want
and nikki's the house today and nikki's
the guest today
yay a lot of nikki's going on
and you're welcome i put them together
and i'm in the hot seat this little
inside baseball for y'all no
together how does it feel like to have
the same names
i like it because she spells it the same
and i don't trust the other ones
n-i-k-k-i what's the other one n-i-c-k
y and i-c-k-i and i-c-k-e-y
and k-k-i-e what are all these extra
letters for i don't know
i hate being around someone else that
has the same name as me how many other
nelson is because there aren't that many
right so i grew up not really
knowing many and then all of a sudden
julia comes along with her boyfriend and
i'm like who is this son of a [ __ ] and
he's cool
that's what i hate about it he's really
cool like at least if you're gonna bring
out nelson he should be like
disgusting piece of [ __ ] i'm like that's
right i am the superior one
yeah but now he's this big buff guy how
do you think i feel nelson
she's a maxim model you're very hold on
wait timeout how do you think i feel
you're actually married yeah i took
myself out of the game that's right i
see i was like i could have been on
maxim but i decided to be married
technically you're technically you're a
playboy model though that's true
really how what does that mean she was
in playboy you were in playboy
not naked though all want oh not
new that's so much better than maxim i
got a butt though
don't look at it don't look at my butt
wait you got a butt on that people get
really offended when she said that she
says that she has a butt because they're
like no you don't that's not oh yeah
this was before people used to buy butts
this was like when you had to grow your
own people get offended well because
now everybody has a big butt but it's
like a actual
big butt but when i was growing up it
was you shouldn't have a big butt and so
people make fun of me for having a butt
and i always wanted a small butt but now
i'm like oh i have a big butt and
they're like no you don't you don't
you wish you had i like girls that walk
like ducks i do walk like that
do i walk like a duck
you should do 20 questions yeah i didn't
know that what else do you like joe
oh yeah what's funny nelson oh i said i
think it's really funny when you watch
like old tv shows especially like from
the 90s
you know where they're always like
because does this make my butt look fat
and then they get so offended if like
anything is not enough that's what it
was like and now it's like does this
make my butt look fat
does it please i'm all right you're like
do i have to completely turn around in
order for you to get this angle
like yeah now there's snapchats and
stuff that show you how to cheat to make
your butt look big i'm like
damn that was not a thing growing up was
it because of the supermodel stuff in
the 90s you wanted to be like
like shaped like cindy crawford [ __ ] i
had no ass
growing up i got made fun of for having
no really yeah
well maybe i did and i just got picked
on i remember this one guy who hits me
up
now see he was picking on you to get
attention she got me
like you have no ass i'm like all i
wanted was a butt so even if i do have a
like a little one
i still probably think that it's not big
enough i have a little complex dang
i just want you have a really nice ass
though thank you yeah it's
huge thank you so do you thank you
say something else you don't think you
have yeah well i would say i don't have
other things but you know obviously
she's never had a ring like it's like
she used to get funnel for not having a
wreath
i found one right here dude i found one
right here gio
geo get your van get your man
he's like here borrow it invite me to
the wedding not true
it's a flexible one it goes on all
different fingers really you're waiting
wait seriously no it's just the silicone
it's for like working out so it's just
the silicone
wow i was like i might be free mine
comes off quickly like i could be like
you forgot yours again didn't you no oh
okay well i'm saying
women look at that a lot like do you
look at a man's hands
to see like oh i do wow and they get
turned on when they see it
yeah [ __ ] yeah they go oh i'm so [ __ ]
horny this guy's taken
it's like an attack vector for something
i think it's kind of that mental thing
that you were talking about earlier on a
different video
where it's like oh she liked him it's
like oh someone likes this guy that must
mean he's taking care of someone
that's what i understand it to be yeah i
don't know i don't find the merry man
attractive like it does it doesn't do it
for me well this married man i find a
friend well he wasn't married when you
found him attractive initially
that's when i was astray that's true
what about friendship bracelets do you
see that and go oh he already has a best
friend
or promise rings if i see a promise i'm
like that is a promise you made a
promise
wow i can't be talking that's a best
friend promise ring man well what about
like the the dad with the kid at the
at the park stereotype where like you
see the dad of the kid and all of a
sudden all these girls got all horny and
[ __ ]
your ovaries start hurting because
you're like really you know how to be
domestic that's hot
yeah oh like you can change a diaper
like i said i would turn somebody into a
stay-at-home dad that one's true
i've never gone for the wedding or
anything but seeing a guy be good with
kids is like
oh that's hard to find it's hard it's
hard to be here with kids you can take
care of them when i need
time to breathe yay i'm gonna need help
have you ever noticed guys faking that
they're good at talking to kids but
they're actually kind of [ __ ] at it no
what does that look like it's pretty
funny actually because they they really
are trying really hard and you're like
kind of like
are you doing this because you're trying
to get with chicks right now like oh
like a guy that doesn't like dogs but
he'll get like a puppy so he could go to
the dog park and pick up on girls yeah
the guy's walking with the dogs i don't
trust them me neither
it's angles guys really are bad at kids
though like there's a
playground next to my house and then so
it'll be me i take taika and then
they'll be geo and then jio's mom
sometimes
and then like it'll be other dads and
other moms and the moms are usually like
five foot radius from the the kid
going down the slide the swings whatever
there's most dads they have the same
protocol they sit there they put on
their earbuds and they're like this
and then and then like every like five
minutes nathan
you know oh you're still there oh [ __ ]
okay all of them i went over to my
brother-in-law's house because our
cousins were there
and my nieces were like just playing in
the cul-de-sac which is like cool
because it's a small town and they could
just play outside
but i was like where's your father
they're like oh he's inside i'm like
he's watching the game
what you mean he's inside and i go over
there and like i was like where's the
babies like oh yeah they're just like
you know riding their bikes down the
street i'm like oh my god somebody
get their asses back over here it's not
the 90s anymore that's how dads watch
kids though
that's really how dad's watching i mean
but here's the thing i got like a
seven-year-old
and like a five-year-old and they're
riding bikes that's too young
but at the same time it is an area they
know everybody there
but i still felt like such a dad thing
because i sat there i was like
oh i'm not telling my sister but you
know what that's y'all issue
not my babies i'm staying out of that
yeah moms are worried
all the time i remember going out and
playing at like seven or eight
just outdoors all day the 90s were just
different
or maybe they weren't but i went out in
the snow all day in the snow
in a blizzard all day i didn't come back
it was dark out my mom's like
maybe they're hoping that you get lost
my mom just wanted to watch oprah and
[ __ ] chill bro yeah i felt like
parents back in the day really just were
like yeah
go be a kid get outside but i think it's
good too
that some kids get to experience that
like my nieces get to actually go and
play outside and like that's pretty damn
dope
and the neighbors kids come over and
they all like one kid came into the
backyard and asked to borrow the scooter
i was like excuse me whose [ __ ] kid
is this
why are you in our backyard and he just
like walked up to
my brother-in-law i was like so uh where
the kids at i was like
you're six why are you talking to him
like that
i remember going to just my friend's
house like hi
mrs grismer is mark home you're like oh
no mark's not home like
okay tell him i was here bye do you guys
used to knock on doors
when you're thirsty yeah yeah you're
just like you have water
you want water yeah just not gonna just
give you water and then you you can i've
never done that
i'm surprised you guys are alive i did
our street was hella tight though like
we would just know that's
a nice old lady so they probably had
chocolate stew if i wanted some
chocolates
my neighbor used to throw candy over the
wall if he heard us playing he would
throw candy we're like israeli candy
that's not completely creepy at all
exactly that's what i'm saying
would go next door now that i think
about it we used to go next door and
have tea parties with the lady
that lived by us she would have like
little tea parties and had cute little
sets oh
yeah but she was looking for the
perversion in that but that's the thing
it was like
if i thought about it now that would be
weird that we were hanging out with an
older lady but back then it was
she was just nice she didn't invent the
pervert yet i don't think or maybe it
was happening but people weren't talking
about it
it didn't go viral yet yeah i'm trying
because i got
lucky there was so many times that could
have happened to me but
[ __ ] man yeah got in the car with
strangers and everything
i think so i wasn't that cute i've
gotten like random rides home from
strangers i remember one time
i got dropped off for like taekwondo as
a kid but turns out it was closed that
day
and my parents didn't know and i was
like crying crying and then just like
a man was like hey are you okay and i'm
like i got dropped off here i need to
like not be here and be at home and he's
like okay i'll take you but like in a
bit
so then he goes in the bar and he's just
drinking with his friends
he comes
i remember it was a bar because it was
like next to the taco no place and i'm
just like
crying and like sobbing a little bit
he's like okay okay let's go
and i just get in the car with this
random guy and i'm like turn left turn
right
and he dropped you off and he dropped me
off i was like alcohol i was like
maybe six seven this is the 90s i was
yeah yeah yeah yeah see everything
happened in the 90s i don't think it was
safer
i just think well there was okay there
would be
less of a oh you probably did something
to my kid versus
oh that's so nice of you to actually
take my crying son home i didn't have a
clue there were no cell phones
oh i think my family was like thank god
you didn't die
or even just i don't want to be in a
situation where i'm putting myself in a
position where i'm with this kid and
then
i'm i'm alone with this kid that's weird
that's what she's saying yeah i think
that's really what ended up changing is
that that's when the
oh you can't do anything nice because
most people even when shit's going down
they're like yo listen i'm not getting
involved i don't want this to turn on me
and i think that's what shifted but
you know do you feel like that could
have been like after the whole entire um
princess diana thing where it's like i'm
involved now like all the reporters are
there but not helping
i don't know but there's a lot of things
that keep me up at night and today's
video is brought
brought to you by call 2020 has been a
lot and we could all benefit from less
stress and more sleep in our lives
it's so important to take care of
ourselves and invest in our well-being
during times of anxiety that's why we're
excited to partner with calm the app
designed to help you ease stress and get
the best sleep of your life and when you
relieve anxiety and improve your sleep
you feel better in every part of your
life com has a whole
library of programs designed for healthy
sleep like soundscapes
guided meditations and over a hundred
sleep stories if you like to hear a
story
uh before you go to sleep and they're
narrated narrated by soothing voices
like stephen fry
kelly rowland and laura dern the world
famous person i never heard of
over 85 million people around the world
use calm to take care of their minds and
get
better sleep and if you go to com.com
off the record you'll get a limited time
offer of 40 off that's almost half
off of a calm premium subscription which
includes hundreds of hours of
programming get the combat
and experience a transformation in the
way you sleep
for listeners of the show com is
offering a special limited time
promotion of 40 off a calm premium
subscription at com.com off the record
that's 40 off unlimited access to com's
entire library and new content is added
every week
get started today at com.com off the
record that's com.com
off the record oh you read that so well
that was really good how well did he
read it so well
do you know what does it do to you when
you it just makes me feel so relaxed
and calm so how many kids do you want
how many kids do you want joe four wow
what that's the magic so much in common
because uh i was born in april so that's
the fourth month
and that made me yeah and there's four
of us there's
four of you guys right first venn
diagram i've ever seen where it's two
circles on top of each other
that's nuts it's not even being in the
middle it's just i don't even know
there's two circles
i don't think there's a venn diagram
with a separate circle it's like a ring
no but usually it's like this yeah yeah
oh but this one's all
right three dimensional venn diagram
everything in common
yeah i see i see yeah do that again how
was it it wasn't
it was put it up so i think you'll see
it better
it's like the circles might be this far
but also why was your first reaction
i i surprised myself for that one i
wasn't sure
[Laughter]
okay nope too soon okay so anyway
and also when you say kelly rowland i
just think of motivation
oh yeah the song what song is that i
think of the one with
the nelly could you imagine her singing
to you
and putting you to sleep oh [ __ ] do you
like that yeah doing it she has a nice
do you like that joe
yeah he likes when i sing only when she
does
right yeah yeah what's going on you guys
are teasing us with this [ __ ] as a
chicken how many kids do you guys want
hmm
we got seven cats right now so you need
seven kids because they all need parents
that's really loud
how do we make this [ __ ] real man i'm so
sick of the teasing yeah
i'm so sick of it because teases all all
formats and all different shows
teasing us on all platforms yeah what
are you guys we're here for the vibe man
yeah that's right merch coming soon um
when you guys are dating in your little
single lives which might not be single
for very much longer
do you guys kiss on the first date um my
friend joe who i love dearly [ __ ] on
the first date need to accept that
whoa whoa whoa how does that make you
feel with him speaking like
he's not wrong question oh thank you i
think the real question isn't if they
kiss on the first date nikki do you like
but on the first date
exactly
don't be a [ __ ] answer the question i'm
so sorry
take a picture take a picture this
moment
guys you aren't helping me right now
dude like [ __ ]
bro how are we [ __ ] dunking it dude
passing back real quick thank you
it's quite aggressive like how do we
even start that so how many feelings do
you show on the first date
there i haven't healthy that's not
healthy if you guys if we
well that's a good feeling smiling's a
feeling for me it is for her for
him okay so if we were to take a
compatibility test like what questions
are on there
i don't think oh you want me to look i
wonder if we are compatible
yeah okay let's do this let's do this we
get along really easy and
like we're just saying on break like
you're uh air or aries and pisces that's
fine no i want to use science
okay i'm just kidding go ahead so we'll
use buzzfeed
the best scientists work there meets
right in the middle uh all of these are
zodiac ones
i have the best questions i have the
best questions but i mean you just asked
me if i eat [ __ ] no that's not
that's
a compatibility he's just best friend
even if she did i wouldn't even like
tell you guys
no that's not a compatibility question
and i'm saying like hi i like to eat
[ __ ] a compatibility question is like
this because you're trying to understand
the inner person right
let's say you're uh it's the end of the
world and it's only you
and your sibling left do you [ __ ] them
to siblings yes do you [ __ ] them to
repopulate the earth or do you say [ __ ]
it that's the end of the human race oh i
guess we're all dying
okay so that's your answer you weren't
even [ __ ] sibling to get
back to human race no they're all gonna
you're more compassionate than that
what's your answer joe
i know my brother i ain't touching that
[ __ ] i can't [ __ ] my brother either
see that you guys are compatible both of
you guys are sympathetic we both
wouldn't [ __ ] our brothers
all right that was really good okay
here's one that's non-astrological
so it must be as good as my question
right as a couple would you say that you
share a call i feel like we're going on
a blind date with our family members
and then they're screening both of us
behind door number one
no we're grilling her okay she's suss do
you share a common vision for your
future well we both want four kids yeah
because that's very common
you both lick butt mm-hmm she wants to
understand his inner being
she does but then i'm gonna talk for her
okay
i'm gonna say she's a lady she's not
gonna admit to it it says mostly yes but
we don't have it all plotted out
we haven't gotten to that conversation
yet how about okay so it's no not really
no at the moment not at the moment but
we'll just see what happens yes
privately
mostly yes but we don't have it all
plotted out or yes we frequently talk
about our future uh that would say
mostly yes but you know we haven't
figured out what we say on camera does
not happen and
you guys agreed on that answer yeah yeah
so one point if someone asked you how
compatible you were as a couple what
would you say
a we're just rubbing along i guess we i
don't
[Laughter]
we don't have that much in common but
we're okay for now c our relationship
isn't perfect but we are strong as a
couple
or d we see ourselves as very connected
and are on the same page about things
that are most important to us
it sounds like we've been dating yeah
like these are questions
i have a better question here's another
question okay here we go if you can make
us [ __ ] a dog bart's test is probably
better yeah this is separately okay
how bad would you [ __ ] here's a
question that's separate
if you guys are flexible enough would
you guys
include oral in your own masturbation
go no so you would you wouldn't eat
yourself out what about you would you
suck your own dick
compatible two for two for experiment
but it's hard to get into it because i
have a dick in my mouth i understand
that you feel like it would just take
too long like what the [ __ ] this is
gonna take forever
it's hard to focus because there's a
dick in my mouth if you're flexible
enough would you rather
suck you don't think or like your own
butt
you know i'll try both questions aren't
very scientific
i will try both anatomy based but the
fact that i have
i have my own parts in my mouth is going
to bother me
is going to buy i think i would just
suck my own balls but not my dick
you have huge balls explain
maybe you don't need to be flexible we
can stretch the balls to you that's true
you know how sometimes you're jerking
off and you kind of hold your balls a
little bit
yeah i just think that if i was holding
him in my mouth
yo that is pretty good though yeah it
feels amazing nice and snug you know
yeah
well you guys are true scientists i love
this group yeah
well it sounds like you guys are pretty
compatible yeah i think based off of
those hard questions yeah
yeah we'd like to see this happen i
think yeah yeah me too we're kids
because we don't want to sleep with our
siblings
and we won't you know eat ourselves out
right
i don't see any other questions no
further questions what else do you need
that's why we need each other
that's true here's a normal one are you
guys adventurous with food that's an
easy one first date where did you take
her
i did ask you that by the way that's a
good question i did ask him that off
camera
i think we're gonna go get some food oh
what kind of oysters why would you get
oyster oh would it be something that
like and it's an aphrodisiac
answered it for me would it be something
that's really weird or something uh
something that you guys both already
know i think we already have this
same likes like i like japanese food i
think
you like sushi a lot right yeah and then
yeah go catch a silent movie or
something so it is something wrong
well i approve i heard you like a silent
movie i hear you
silent but i'm catching it he nasty so i
know
yeah he's got a dirty [ __ ] dark mind
i feel like our first date is gonna be
with you guys there too
right it's probably gonna be like an
extreme double that's gonna be like
right now
how's this going how is this are you
guys having fun they're gonna order the
food for us they're gonna send it over
for us
it's like a traditional asian date with
your family there
hey do you think you're gonna [ __ ]
tonight i got this right now
okay thanks for letting us know no
they're not gonna [ __ ] do you feel like
we're 13
and our parents are like on this date
with us have you ever had your parents
set you up
i have had my child i tried so how did
that go does that is that what it feels
like i didn't like my mom's taste
hell no she was always trying to hook me
up and i was like man
come on my dad had good taste actually
yeah but my mom asked me now like so the
holidays are coming around
are you dating anybody yet like
no kiss let's do it then
[Music]
you